un manto de nieve cubre franjas de eeuu
donde vive gente que no está
acostumbrada a este frío extremo una
tormenta de invierno ha provocado varias
muertes en cuatro estados algunos
murieron tratando de mantenerse en calor
dentro de sus propias casas millones de
personas siguen sin electricidad en
texas debido a la alta demanda esta
gente de houston se ha visto obligada a
buscar refugio en una iglesia local
dejamos nuestra casa porque estaba muy
fría y nos intoxicamos del monóxido de
carbono hacía demasiado frío para estar
en casa sin comida sin agua no podíamos
cocinar y por eso vinimos
las autoridades locales están en el
centro de las críticas por el
desabastecimiento de agua y electricidad
mientras tanto las compañías eléctricas
implementaron apagones temporales para
evitar sobrecargar se ha hecho en
uruguay works pidió una orden efectiva a
partir de hoy hasta el 21 de febrero
para requerir que los productores que
envían gas natural fuera de texas lo
vendan a los generadores de energía de
texas
la tormenta ya se aleja de texas pero
los oficiales advierten que las
temperaturas invernales seguirán durante
días mientras la tempestad se mueve
hacia el noreste se espera hielo granizo
y fuertes nevadas en louisiana arkansas
y misisipí